distribution de kits pour arrêter de
fumer prescription d'ordonnancé ou
simplement besoin de conseils ils
étaient une dizaine ce matin à la gare
de saint quentin en yvelines pour
sensibiliser un maximum de personnes ce
qui a beaucoup gens qui veulent arrêter
de fumer que ça peut être pas trop
comment faire ou qui se sont heurtés à
des difficultés lors de leur art
précédent donc on est là pour leur
donner plus d'outils will de moyens et
pour les aider à atteindre leurs
objectifs au bout de 30 jours les
symptômes liés au manque sont largement
réduits et les premiers bénéfices
apparaissent des bénéfices qui sont
d'ordre financier ils sont barde du
souffle de la santé de l'état de santé
général de retrouve le droit le bout il
ya beaucoup de choses déjà très très
évidente bout d'un mois dans le mois
sans tabac facilite également l'accès à
un entretien avec un professionnel de
santé et jacques sont très accros aux
gestes et ses salons il va avoir besoin
de dons qui va avoir du mal à se passer
et il ya des gens qui vont être très
accros au compteur à la nicotine donc
pour cela et pas je sais pas si ça
suffira largement un suivi personnalisé
puisque les personnes qui repartent avec
une ordonnance seront recontactés dans
les mois à venir pour prendre rendez
vous je ponds mais pas chez mais parce
qu'il est on doit se
reprendre contact il s'agirait de deux
de trop mais je voulais arrêter ce matin
puis finalement
je suis direct l'emportera pasqua les
personnes souhaitant arrêter de fumer
peuvent également appeler le 39 89
télécharger l'application du coaching
tabac info service ou encore s'inscrire
sur des groupes d'entre elles via
facebook